[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nous vous avions
promis une surprise à voici coup ou
c'est une belle surprise vous savez
voici mes quatre neveux
oscar
fait nos dos et me toto et fanfan
ou est il celui là ah le voilà
allons de la discipline mes neveux
vous m'avez promis d'être sage et de
bien vous tenir
ne l'oubliez pas
descendez rémi toto enfants oscar une
ourse
papa
beau soir nicolas rebond soit pas prodel
voici une surprise
cberger
sur césar
allons du calme mais le voeu du
salut d'auto bouillon
m
alors les enfants vous êtes coteaux
merci
[Musique]
il a une bonne mine c'est un petit temps
oui mais il faut le boucher il as rome
j'avais les mettre dans mon dire c'est
tout et me vient en tête est ce qu un
mois je me préparais à biberon avec un
peu niall est pas trop fort
et voilà notre petit sk chérie je m'en
moque bien de nous tuer de très bonnes
petites mamans pas preneur au masseur
immédiat va être bien contre
nicolas
voilà
tient tp zala au biberon connaître des
déviants aux nuits oscars
mais nous sont rémi toto et fanfan
au lit des gens
[Musique]
besson dormez bien tôt mais on va
s'amuser
près d'eux pour
bonne nuit les enfants
admis annie
oscar d'or des gens
non j'ai tant la lune
[Musique]
alors nounours tout va bien tout est
pour le mieux patron ils dorment tous
ouf quel jour mais
on s'en va oui en route nounours
bonne nuit des enfants allez vite vous
couchez vous aussi eu photo bourg
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o o
[Musique]